let's hear from Charlie Lynch I think
that's a great idea we're teetering on
the cusp of change and the change is
coming eventually but for some some
people like me and Virgil who's in the
crowd here I don't know if that change
is going to be in time to keep us out of
jail and not ask Obama to step up to the
plate also at this point and you know we
let give us some clear guidelines you
know let's see this new written policy
on paper make it clear to it so we
understand what the new policy is
charles complied with all the
regulations was issued a business
license complied with all those
conditions so that's primarily what I
testified is the fact that at all times
Charles linch was a law abiding a
citizen as far as his business was
concerned in morro bay i asked the
adjoining businesses to let me know if
they had any concerns or problems never
once was i called there's only one
complaint that i received and that had
to do with the quality of the medical
it had nothing to do with illegal
trafficking people without prescriptions
or recommendations from the doctor
sounds like you have the judges sympathy
at one point said run my preference if I
can find a way out I would not see a way
to give you anything left for the year
right yeah I think the judge he's
mentioned that the mandatory minimums
are definitely not fair in this case and
he's mentioned that he's found by
federal law so he's looking for ways i
believe to to keep me out of jail i hope
and seems like it a fair compassionate
judge in a lot of cases actually it's
it's the federal laws that are unfair i
don't think judge was really that unfair
as mr. Cohen does the judge give you a
road map to guide you to get this down
to one year I think he gave us a road
map to get it down to probation I do
think that the judge understands the
irony of hearing President Obama's using
words like medical marijuana an attorney
general saying things like medical
marijuana when in fact we were told at
trial that there is no such thing as
medical marijuana you were the one who
put up the four hundred thousand dollars
bail can you explain that and and how it
affected your family and and what that
money was originally going towards I
didn't put up the entire four hundred
thousand dollars i put up the cash
portion of the bail and that money was
originally used or intended for my
children's college education early on in
the trial there was some implication
that the cash was coming from illegal
funds through me and I resented that and
so who made us suggestion that was from
the prosecution
and I resented being associated with
illegal activities that money was hard
earned that I put up but we were glad to
do it to help Charlie are you more or
less optimistic than you were at the
beginning of the day I am a little
optimistic i came down prepared
literally to drive Charlie's car home in
the event he was taken away and have a
letter on things that I need to take
care of his affairs so I was prepared
for that basically hope for the best but
prepare for the worst fortunately that
did not happen today and we'll see what
happens in Jews